Цей візит у США українського президента Володимира Зеленського
без перебільшення називають історичним. У своїй емоційній промові
на спільному засіданні Сенату та Палати представників Конгресу США Зеленський пояснив,
заради чого українці понад 300 днів борються з прямою агресією Росії і надихають світ.
Ця битва не лише за життя, свободу та безпеку українців чи будь-якого іншого народу,
який Росія прагне підкорити. Ця боротьба визначить, в якому світі житимуть
наші діти та онуки. А потім їхні діти та онуки. Вона визначить,
чи це буде демократія для українців і для американців. Для всіх.
Президент передав Конгресу бойовий прапор з Бахмута, де нині тривають
одні з найзапекліших боїв з військами РФ.
Нехай цей прапор залишиться з вами. Пані та панове, цей прапор є символом
нашої перемоги у цій війні. Ми стоїмо, боремося і переможемо, тому що ми єдині.
Україна, Америка і весь вільний світ.
Президент США Джо Байден запевнив, що Україна ніколи не залишиться наодинці
і Сполучені Штати підтримуватимуть Київ стільки, скільки буде потрібно,
і єдність союзників - непохитна.
Я не бачу жодних підстав вважати, що буде якесь призупинення підтримки,
і коли ми звертаємося до наших союзників у НАТО, нашого міністра оборони,
нашого держсекретаря, ми отримуємо постійну підтримку не тільки там,
але й з усього світу - з Японії та багатьох інших країн.
Тому я дуже добре відчуваю солідарну підтримку України.
"Путін - більше не суб’єкт цивілізованих людей, людина з хворим відношенням до світу",
- емоційно заявив Зеленський, пояснюючи, чому більше не потрібно посилати меседжі
президенту РФ Путіну. Водночас Чарльз Купчан, який працював спецпомічником
президента США Барака Обами, коли почалася війна на Донбасі,
і часто бував у Києві та Москві, вважає, що сам візит Зеленського
і позиція США - це вже красномовне послання Путіну.
Я думаю, що меседж Путіну насправді такий: ми не відступаємо,
ми не втрачаємо терпіння. Ми будемо продовжувати підтримувати відважні зусилля України
щодо самозахисту, які наразі виявилися надзвичайно ефективними.
Це війна, яку Путін програє. Він ще не визнав, що це так.
Але хоробрий бойовий дух України в поєднанні з підтримкою її союзників
виявився надзвичайно ефективним
і завдає вирішальної стратегічної поразки спробам Путіна підкорити Україну.
Сполучені Штати оголосили про черговий пакет допомоги для України
на майже 2 мільярди доларів, в рамках якого будуть надані артилерійські системи,
боєприпаси та довгоочікувані системи протиповітряної оборони Patriot.
Я думаю, що для США це є ознакою прихильності до України,
тому що протягом останніх тижнів було багато публікацій, в яких намагалися
дискредитувати українську армію або її зусилля, особливо щодо ЗАЕС,
а також порушень прав людини. Тож, це ознака того, що США й надалі
віддані підтримці України і вірять у те, що українська армія може протистояти російській агресії.
А також надіслати меседж своїм союзникам, які уповільнюють підтримку України
через власні національні інтереси, підтримати українську армію.
І це продемонстрували атаки на Крим, а також на Антонівський міст,
які були успішними з тактичної точки зору.
Отже, ідея полягає в тому, щоб підтримувати і надавати більше зброї.
Надання Україні американських ЗРК Patriot, за словами експертів, буде недостатньо,
щоб захистити все українське небо від атак Росії.
Навіть недостатньо для цілковитого захисту Києва, але достатньо, щоб вплинути
на аргументи Берліна, який, зокрема щодо танків, постійно повторював,
що не буде надавати їх наодинці, а лише разом із союзниками по НАТО.
Сполучені Штати, передаючи ЗРК Patriot, дають сигнал іншим союзникам по НАТО,
включаючи Німеччину, що, мовляв, не бійтеся, не бійтеся надсилати
більш досконалу зброю в Україну. Як Patriot, що є однією з найсучасніших
протиракетних систем. Але є також танки і, можливо, врешті-решт літаки,
які також будуть поставлені в Україну. Тож це дуже сильний як військовий,
так і політичний сигнал від Сполучених Штатів.
Німеччина не наважилася відправити систему Patriot безпосередньо до України,
надавши її натомість Польщі для розміщення неподалік кордону з Україною.
Нині ж рішення США надати Києву ці зенітно-ракетні комплекси
кардинально змінює дискусію в Німеччині, вважають опитані DW експерти та політики.
Ми вже кілька місяців обговорюємо, що росіяни можуть не виграти, а Україна - не програти.
Чи ми повинні вийти за рамки цього і сказати, що Росія має бути переможена,
а Україна має виграти цю війну? Думаю, зараз це дуже зрозуміло.
У Німеччині та Європі ми також маємо чітко визначити це питання.
Будь-який інший результат був би набагато, набагато важчим, набагато дорожчим,
більш кривавим для всіх у Європі, не тільки в Україні, для багатьох інших.
І тому ми маємо чітко розуміти цей стратегічний політичний меседж,
що Україна має досягти перемоги.
Цей особистий візит Зеленського, а не просто відеозвернення -
також і потужний сигнал Конгресу. Американські законотворці нині розглядають
надання Україні багатомільярдної допомоги, і їм було важливо почути,
що гроші підуть за призначенням і Києву можна довіряти.
Не випадково, що Конгрес нині проводить дебати щодо дуже значного
додаткового пакету допомоги на 45 мільярдів доларів для України перед тим,
як цей склад Конгресу піде на свята.
Адже ніхто не знає, як відбуватимуться ці дебати, коли республіканці отримають контроль
над Палатою представників. Я вважаю, що приїзд Зеленського до Вашингтона,
щоб виступити перед Конгресом, дуже корисний, оскільки це створить відчуття
громадського співчуття, емпатії до України. І я думаю, що це допоможе підтримувати
двопартійну підтримку допомоги США Україні в новому році.
Конгресмени - і демократи, і республіканці - 21 раз стоячи оваціями
переривали виступ президента України. За словами президента Байдена,
намагання Путіна послабити Захід та НАТО
насправді лише зміцнили трансатлантичні відносини.